this whole thing really hasn't changed
me I mean I just get recognized now you
know by kids and stuff it's great to be
able to be a positive role model on kids
[Music]
I'm Jason David Frank and I play Tommy
the White Ranger E.T looks back at our
time with Jason David Frank as his Power
Rangers co-stars speak out following his
death you know everything we've been
through together
hi
it's Amy Jo
he's thinking about Jason a lot and um
and I hope you guys are okay
I know how much
how much you all meant to him you know
what's crazy with the Power Ranger movie
with the consistency of the brand it's
because I'm signing the you know things
for little kids and then their parents
are fans and their moms know who I am so
it's like three different Generations
[Music]
very important question why do you think
that Tommy and Kimberly did not end up
together well uh Kimberly wrote me that
letter Kimberly you wrote me that break
that was the meanest coldest thing I've
ever seen on a show it was it was all
right I moved on but hopefully I forgive
you I forgive you Kimberly hey beautiful
it's time to wake up
I don't believe it
I know all of you are so sad I'm
thinking about all of you guys
I don't know I'm sending you all love
Jason tapped into his real life skills
as a mixed martial artist behind the
scenes we'll just take a square horse
has a musician with practices practice
dance do single punches ready and Butch
ERS
David Yost penned a heartfelt tribute on
Instagram writing quote you had my heart
on day one so intelligent so funny so
energetic you shaped and transformed so
many lives you know it's important for
the kids to look up to someone and
that's you know us for now
what would you guys say is the question
that you get asked the most at
conventions do you like green or white
that's the most common question I get
and then I say green they're like sorry
I'm a white ranger fan I'm like that's
still me like you know what I mean I
think after years three years you know
we always continue to change with the
ninjetti and stuff like that it keeps
the kids interested you know and it
gives the show a whole new look you know
I think it's important for the kids you
know I think it's important for them to
see constant change and change is good I
mean the kids enjoy that the thing is
I'm proud of Power Rangers is that we
were the number one kid show in the
world you've been on I believe more
episodes than anybody like well over 200
I don't even know do you know how many I
think 230ish Tommy was a very limited
character he's supposed to come in and
out in about 10 episodes what happened
was when the Green Ranger lost his
powers people all over the world were
like petitioning and telling Saban we
need you know kids aren't going to
school kids aren't eating your true hero
Tommy thanks guys you know there was a
moment back there when I almost gave up
but then I realized it's not just a
costume and power that gives me strength
but it's who and what I am inside that
really empowers me but then they brought
me back as the White Ranger and it's
been about 25 years and you know it's
just amazing to see the fans and to see
the kids grow into a whole new
generation
[Music]
guess who's back